d'abord vous avez raison merci de me
permettre de revenir sur sur ce sujet
ayant évoqué l'attaque terroriste du
Hamas contre Israël toutes les vies se
valent et nous sommes bouleversés par
aujourd'hui les vies qui sont touchées à
Gaza et qui sont en quelque sorte la
conséquence de cette attaque terroriste
du Hamas et la responsabilité est
immense de ce groupe terroriste qui a
déclenché cette
riposte je l'ai dit nous menons des
opérations
humanitaires multiples
avec nos militaires avec nos diplomates
avec nos largages fra médicaments vivre
en périphérie et sur la bande de Gaza
mais la priorité est de cesser le feu
j'ai quasiment chaque semaine le Premier
ministre netaniahou en
ligne nous réitérons cela avec
d'ailleurs plusieurs puissances de la
région les États-Unis d'Amérique l'ont
également fait et nous soutiennent dans
cette approche c'est une priorité
pourquoi parce que après plus de 100
jours ce sont maintenant des opérations
ciblées qui doivent être conduites et il
faut
concilier la défense d'Israël et la
poursuite des terroristes avec la
préservation du droit
humanitaire et je le dis parce que c'est
aussi l'intérêt l'intérêt sur le plan de
la sécurité à long terme
d'Israël et que poursuivre aujourd'hui
les opérations telles qu'elles sont
conduites c'est prendre un risque
compris dans la durée comptetenue de ce
que cela faêtre dans toute la région
pour la sécurité d'Israël même donc nous
allons poursuivre les initiatives
diplomatiques
résolution discussion pour appeler à un
cesser le feu et je vais poursuivre le
contact bilatéral pour essayer de
l'obtenir de manière très concrète c'est
ça maintenant la priorité car on sait
c'est ce qui permettra d'aller au
contact des populations de les protéger
et tout ça est lié à quoi à une
stratégie odieuse qui est la stratégie
du pire celle utilisée par le Hamas qui
met ses réserves d'armes et ses centres
de décision sous les écoles caché dans
les hôpitaux qui utiliseent comme
bouclier une partie de la population
civile mais au point au moment où nous
en sommes et la France dit cela depuis
plusieurs
semaines nous devons cesser ces attaques
qui sont par trop indifférencié et nous
devons protéger les populations civiles
c'est un devoir humanitaire parce qu'il
peut pas y avoir de standard et que
toutes les vies se Val donc on va
poursuivre le travail et je peux pas
vous dire qu'on est réussi aujourd'hui
et que je m'en considère comme satisfait
je vois avec la même douleur que vous
les scènes que nous voyons et je sais
aussi ce que cela produit dans chez
beaucoup de nos compatriotes et dans
beaucoup de pays de la
région je le disais nous nous battons
pour lutter contre les terroristes nous
nous battons pour le cesser le feu pour
la réponse humanitaire et nous nous
battons pour qu'il y ait une vraie
réponse dans la durée à l'aspiration
légitime du peuple palestinien pour
avoir un état parce que c'est ça qui
apportera la sécurité et la stabilité
dans la durée et je ne voudrais pas que
ce qui est en train de se passer
compromettent la possibilité d'une
solution
politique
I